they're here right here in our lobby in
the lobby of financial peace Plaza
standing in Martha's place Michael and
Larina are with us hey guys welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave thanks for
joining us here in Nashville where do
you live we live in Frisco Texas a
little north of Dallas yes 25 miles
north of Dallas little north of Plano or
McKinney then yes okay very cool fun
well welcome to Nashville what brings
you to Nashville well we're here second
time at the financial peace peace Plaza
first time we were here was to do our
ministry counseling for our church Hope
fellowship and this time we're here to
yell our debt free scream I love that
very cool well God so how much of you
guys paid off um $450,000 in the last
seven years Wow does that include your
house we have our primer resident and a
rental all paid for well pay for we owe
nobody nothing as young as you are that
is amazing what kind of income during
that seven years um we went from about
98 to a little over three hundred okay
ring ding ding what you do to cause that
to happen I work for corporate America
but she had decided to when she went
from civil engineer to become a realtor
and in first couple of years was you
know we're just making a little bit of
income and then we had she was pregnant
with him and did a lot of marketing
while she was on bed rest at the
hospital mm-hmm and after that you know
God just really blesses us and uh things
that just took off and you know we've
been blessed since turns out Larina can
sell some real estate yes she can once a
while I do that yeah once in a while
every 20 seconds another house goes down
at that that's awesome so you know on
top of that I actually just quit my
corporate job on Friday to become a full
time realtor with her as well so husband
if you're good enough you make your
husband your assistant yeah that
how it works yeah that's good I like it
way to go you guys well you could do
that I mean you could make choices now
you got a great income number one a
great business bill number two you know
I mean dad got payments that's right
Dave absolutely awesome way to go you
guys so what inspired you to do this
seven years ago what what started this
journey I don't know it's just uh I'll
let her tell her well we've always
wanted to be debt-free but we never
quite know how to do that and being the
engineer that I am I found this guy who
was screaming at this person who was in
a truck one day you know I was listening
to this crazy guy I was like oh my gosh
this guy is crazy so I turned off the
radio and six months later I tuned back
in and I said you know what I like steps
and I like the seven baby steps on I'm
an engineer I can follow steps and we
just keep on going even if he's crazy
he's got good steps exactly yeah I like
it okay but you know Dave we're we were
not born in America we came up to us
I've been here about 19 years and she's
been here for 18 years we grew up never
known anything about credit card the
first credit card was my dad got me
before I board plane come to America and
we both went to school here but that was
more of the you know just in case
emergency you know situation so we've
had a card and then we went to school
and graduated got a job you know having
credit cards and then once she found you
you know it was it was hard to give up I
actually cut up my card two years after
we actually were 100% on board Dave I
still have my Citibank card back then
and then when I cut it up and I was just
a great you know freedom and so you
weren't married when you came here no
did you know each other even no we we
met in the University of Oklahoma okay
that's fun and what country are you from
Malaysia both of you okay that's
interesting you know why don't you fight
two Malaysians find each other in
Oklahoma yes yeah that's right that's
that happens all the time
yeah
Wow you know one of the most inspiring
things that I really want to I we drove
10 hours here with two young kids here
is wanting to share our story here
mm-hmm the most important thing is that
what I what I found was when America
says that this is the land of
opportunity
they really really mean it all we really
had to do is just work hard and
everything well we'll go for you if you
just dare work hard you live less than
you make and you be contented with what
you have and that's how we paid off
$150,000 in seven years you guys are
awesome that's so inspiring you know
what's interesting is and now how did
you immigrate from there legally how
does that happen
Camaros good and then work your way into
citizenship yes and that process took us
11 years okay eleven years before we
were a US citizen but you know on on top
of what she said being being frugal
being contented you know we the amount
that we make we actually live probably
one-fifth of what what our income is and
we don't do a lot of fun stuff but we
work she does a lot of work and I help
her and just you know doing the work
it's kinda like our vacation and you
know she doesn't like to go to any
vacation her vacation is pretty much you
know blogging online looking for real
estate
you know stuff to do but that's kind of
how we were able to pay off for and
fifty thousand already impressive you
guys it's a lot of money yeah it's a
very very very cool story the eight out
of ten millionaires in America today are
first generation rich but here's the
other interesting statistic someone who
does what you've done come here and go
through the legal process from another
country you're four times more likely to
become millionaires than one of us good
old boys who is homegrown here Wow
because there's something about when you
say there's that this is the land of
opportunity that's different then when
an old redneck guy like me says it you
know because it's just like you you
embody it you're a walking talking
testimony to people you can do this no
excuses allowed and you know is it hard
what
yeah it's hard you don't become the
queen a real estate without working your
butt off yeah I mean you know it's hard
but but it's worth it that's the thing
there's a payoff at the end of this it's
a sacrifice that you know sometimes we
don't even get to eat dinner together
and most of the weekends either I become
stay-at-home dad and she goes out or we
get a babysitter and both of us go out
on you know on appointments but you know
at the end of the at the end of the day
on Sunday when we go to church and you
know we take our kids to church you know
we kind of feel like it's kind of got
what God wants us to do is you know just
I wasn't much older than your son just a
little bit older than him when my
parents are in the real estate business
put me on the business end of a paint
brush on houses they were buying I mean
we started painting houses and cleaning
up the yard and stuff when I was a kid I
remember doing that stuff and it it
taught me how to do things and it taught
me not only how to work with my hands
but how to work hard and how to do stuff
and you're set up for that I mean this
is this is awesome well I'm so proud of
y'all you're inspiring thank you so much
for sharing with us and you're one of
our endorsed local providers out here
yes yes we are we also do a financial
counseling at church you know just just
to help out because that's that's one
thing is paying off the debt has allowed
us to do what God at least what we feel
that God's calling us to do is to serve
real estate it's just this is a way of
serving you know it's our ministry to a
lot of people that either move to Frisco
or from out of state out of country we
just want to just make sure that we're
following God's calling we don't we
don't go to a third world country as a
mission couple but you know real estate
is our is our mission ground that's cool
I'm with you that that's awesome
now your mom and dad when they see this
stuff what do they think my dad is not a
big fan of the dish ha ha ha ha
sorry Dave it's ok it's truthful my dad
knows are they in the States my dad my
parents are and his parents are living
in leisure ok my my dad when when he
thinks that were not spending heed I
don't think he really knows how much we
make until now he knows we we make a
very good living but he thinks that we
we are just too crazy for not spending
our money and enjoying our life yeah
yeah I hear you that's fun well very
cool well congratulations you
all right it's Michael and lorina from
Dallas Texas 450,000 dollars paid off in
seven years making 98 now 300,000 a year
you guys are inspiring count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one Wow Wow
makes you want to stand up and sing god
bless the USA or play at least Lee
Greenwood doing it man I just got to
tell you if you hear that kind of stuff
and you think you can't win I got one
word for you shut up that's awesome
that's so inspiring this is the Dave
Ramsey show
you